l'homosexualité est une calamité pour la
santé publique
une décomposition des moeurs pour la
jeunesse une criminalité pour la société
un péché mortel pour l'église une
perversion pour la famille 10 mars 2001
dans la rubrique publicité du
nouvelliste journal valaisan en suisse 6
septembre 2019 ce soir en valais je
relis ces propos qui reste d'actualité
et je ne suis pas une calamité
je ne participe pas à la décomposition
des moeurs je ne suis pas une criminelle
je ne suis pas un péché mortel
je ne suis pas une perversion avant de
devenir il faut exister les violences
poussent à l'exil psychique biographique
géographique pouvoir être soi ne va pas
de soi alors ce soir je vous invite à
réfléchir à cette double question en
quoi les violences en retz les de venir
et comment ouvrir l'avenir afin de
décrypter la manière dont les violences
se déploie et leurs répercussions
je vous propose d'explorer la métaphore
de l'épée de damoclès cette métaphore
provient de mes activités de recherche
et de formation
et pour commencer dont le vif du sujet
partons de l'iceberg des violences et de
sa pointe à savoir l'injure et
j'aimerais savoir qui dans la salle a
déjà été une fois dans sa vie
la cible d'injures quelle que soit cette
injure je vous prie de lever la main
merci beaucoup merci deuxième question
qui dans la salle a déjà été témoin
d'une injure quelle qu'elle soit merci
beaucoup
dernière question qui dans la salle a
déjà été aux tris ou auteur d' injure je
remercie beaucoup pour votre honnêteté
c'est beaucoup plus facile de lever la
main quand on dit ah je suis témoin que
autrice aux auteurs cette entrée par
l'injure et vos mains qui se lèvent
permettent de constater que l'injure
concerne tout le monde
c'est une expérience commune parce
qu'elle est partagée
mais c'est une expérience spécifique
parce qu'elle varie en fonction des vécu
cette expérience de l'injure même les
enfants savent ce que c'est
quand je travaille avec des
professionnels qui accompagnent des
enfants et des jeunes souvent les
professionnels me disent oui mais les
enfants ne savent pas toujours ce que
les injures veulent dire si vous avez
tout à fait raison même certains ou
certaines adultes ne savent pas ce que
veulent dire certaines injures dont vous
avez tout à fait raison
par contre même les enfants comprennent
que c'est pas pour faire du bien
autrement dit les injures ce sont des
mots pas comme les autres ce sont à ce
point des mots pas comme les autres que
ce sont des violences verbales et
qu'elle tombe sous le coup de la loi
ce sont des mots pas comme les autres
parce qu'elle blesse en plein coeur
comme une épée on arrive à notre épée de
damoclès pourquoi l'épée de damoclès
parce que l'injure à la le pouvoir de
blessés et de dévaloriser et de damoclès
parce que dans les entretiens que je
mène dans mes recherches
j'entends très souvent des personnes qui
me disent moi je n'ai jamais été la
cible directe d'injures mais le fait que
ça puisse arriver m'angoisse alors je
fais gaffe c'est à dire que cette
métaphore nous permet de montrer que les
injures
telle une épée de damoclès plane c'est
un fantôme menaçons qui peut s'abattre à
tout moment et qui a un outil de
contrôle et de sanction l'épée de
damoclès c'est aussi une manière de
mettre en évidence que très souvent dans
le contexte scolaire les élèves me
disent c'est violent d'être la cible de
violences c'est encore plus violent
quand les adultes n'interviennent pas ce
point est crucial puisqu'il nous met en
évidence que le fait de bouger par
rapport aux épées de damoclès sauve des
vies
et le fait de ne pas bouger par rapport
aux épée damoclès c'est une manière de
légitimer les violences et de dire qu'on
est d'accord avec elle c'est d'autant
plus important que comme on vient de le
dire
l'injure c'est que la pointe de
l'iceberg des violences parce
qu'effectivement il existe aussi les
violences physiques les coûts par
exemple mais aussi les violences
sexuelles attouchements viols etc et on
va maintenant s'intéresser plus
précisément aux violences sexistes et
sexuelles
pourquoi se pencher davantage sur ces
violences là et ces injures là pour la
simple et bonne raison qu au sommet du
hit parade des injures se trouvent les
injures sexistes et homophobes
alors je vais pas citer les injures
sexistes la plus connue est l' injure
homophobe la plus connue par contre je
peux vous donner un indice elle commence
les deux par p on pourrait appeler ça le
paie au carré et puis que c'est devenu
des vrais signes de ponctuation donc ces
deux injures sont au sommet du hit
parade et elle traverse les cours de
récré le contexte professionnel
les stades de foot les réseaux sociaux
les repas de famille donc c'est vraiment
sur cet aspect là qu'on va se centrer
actuellement et pour bien comprendre à
quoi elle referme
on va prendre deux registres différents
c'est à dire le premier quand est ce que
les épées tombe sur les questions de
genre et le deuxième quand est ce que
sexualité
on commence par le genre exemple très
familier une épée damoclès c'est-à-dire
un rappel à l'ordre peu tombé par
rapport à une fille qui fait du foot ou
un garçon qui joue à la poupée mais on
voit qu'il ya pas les mêmes enjeux
qui se développe pourquoi la fille qui
fait du foot on va lui dire quand même
ces soi-disant pas une activité pour les
filles mais elle gravite vers le côté
qui est socialement valorisé alors que
le petit garçon lui là rien pigé il est
en train de jouer à la poupée donc lui
qui gravitent dans le mauvais sens
c'est à dire qui gravite vers le côté
qui est moins valorisé socialement donc
cet exemple nous permet de montrer que
les personnes qui refusent de se plier
aux stéréotypes de genre ont la
possibilité d'être remise à l'ordre
et ça nous permet d'attaquer ce concept
de genre puisque le genre est un concept
et ce concept c'est un outil d analyse
pour comprendre comment se passe la
construction des masculinités des
féminité mais ce concept va plus loin
puisqu'il nous montrent qu'effectivement
c'est un système hiérarchique puisque le
masculin va être socialement valorisé au
détriment du féminin pourquoi je vous
parle de ses joues m parce qu'en fait
les jouets sais pas si anodin parce que
les jouets quand on y joue on ne
développe pas les mêmes compétences et
d'autre part les jouer quand on y joue
ça ne préfigure pas les mêmes rôles
sociaux
on pourrait faire vraiment cet exemple
de trottinettes versus poussette ses
outils et ses jouets fleurissent dans
les catalogues pour enfants souvent très
bleu et très rose je reviendrai sur les
couleurs tout à l'heure mais c'est une
manière de dire que le message qu'on
donne à une ou un enfant
tiens prends une trottinette et découvre
le monde tiens prends à poussettes et
prendra le trottoir c'est déjà plus
difficile pour aller explorer le monde
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que c'est des assignations sociale c'est
à dire que le gène du ballon n'existe
pas le gène du caquelon non plus et puis
le gène de l'aspirateur on le cherche
encore c'est parce qu'à des personnes
qui ont beaucoup passer l'aspirateur
qu'elles sont devenues très forte on
aspirateur heureusement maintenant il
existe des aspirateurs qui font
l'aspirateur tout seul enfin faut-il
encore avoir les moyens de se l'acheter
on est bien d'accord
ce que je voulais mettre en évidence par
là c'est que les épées de damoclès
peuvent tomber sur ce qu'on appelle les
rôles de genre c'est à dire les
activités mais les jouets et ses
activités se cristallisent dans le
contexte professionnel puisque dans le
contexte professionnel on
ou dit aussi qu'il y aurait des filières
dites féminines dites masculines
alors qu'en fait on développe des
compétences quel que soit ce qu'on a
entre les gens développent des
compétences et sa se cristallisent
encore plus dans la question de la
discrimination salariale puisque on voit
que sur un même critère même travail on
a une inégalité de traitement
et là on est dans de la discrimination
puisque sur un critère injustifiable on
fait un traitement qui est inégal donc
les épées tombe sur les rôles de genre
les activités expression de genre pour
exemplifier l'expression de genre je
vais vous parler en fait de ma question
existentielle que j'avais quand j'étais
enfant
quand j'étais enfant j'étais vraiment en
train de me demander par rapport à mes
cheveux
à partir de combien de centimètres
exactement jallet virée dans le pôle
soi-disant basculant dans le pôle
soi-disant féminin je me disais mais qui
fixe ces critères et puis qui a décidé
nombre de centimètres puis du coup
dernièrement j'ai revu un album de
jeunesse et je me voit sur cette photo
et j'avais la coupe du mulet donc je
regarde cette photo je me suis dit c'est
intéressant la coupe du mulet c'est
court dessus long derrière mais pour ne
pas stigmatiser les personnes qui
auraient la coupe du 1000m qui redevient
à la mode entre parenthèses enfin ça
dépend où et par qui
même ça c'est un autre sujet mais donc
je regarde cette coupe du mulet elle
était particulière parce que j'avais eu
la bonne idée de déteindre mais que
draps en blond platine
je me suis dit que c'était assez
impressionnant comme idée mais je
pensais pas que j'allais pouvoir devenir
quelqu'un ou quelqu'une de cette manière
là mais en tout cas je me suis dit que
je regarde cette photo j'ai cette coupe
du mulet puis je me suis dit mais cette
coupe du mulet ceni masculin ni féminin
c'est moche en fait et là je me suis dit
je me suis peut-être trompé de questions
enfin pas tant que ça puisque je suis
encore en train de vous parler de ça ce
soir
ma question c'était laquelle s'était
mais pourquoi on divise le monde en deux
et qui veut viser le monde en deux dont
je peux maintenant rallier rôles de
genre qui le sont les activités et
l'expression de jean repenser la coupe
du mulet comme ça vous confondez pas
l'expression de jean en fait c'est tout
les codes sociaux que ce soit les
vêtements les postures les accessoires
et ses conclusions
de la rubrique de quand est-ce que
l'épée tombe sur les questions de genre
c'est vraiment une manière de mettre en
évidence qu'on a un pouvoir d'action
très fort sur cet aspect là parce qu'on
peut décoller justement notre pensée de
notre nombril très facilement par
exemple en faisant un pas en arrière on
se rend compte que c'est que à partir
des années 1900 que le bleu il a été
assigné aux garçons et le rose aux
filles
avant cela c'était complètement l'
inverse donc il suffit de faire un petit
pas en arrière pour se dire que non les
filles ne court pas frénétiquement après
le rose et les garçons n'ont pas le gène
du bleu ce serait plutôt le gène des
schtroumpfs d'ailleurs que le gène
je ne sais quoi mais donc un petit pas
en arrière ne nous fait jamais de mal
parce que ça veut dire que ça n'a pas
toujours été comme ça on peut aussi
faire un pas de côté et un pas de côté
on pourrait tout à fait prendre
l'exemple de l'ecosse ou plein d'hommes
se baladent avec des kilts on pourrait
appeler ça des jupes et ça ne pose de
problème à aucune personne pourquoi je
vous donne cet exemple parce qu en fait
rien n'est gravé dans le marbre et ses
assignations sociale
elles sont très situer au niveau
culturel et historique autre piste très
concrètes
c'est justement de travailler sur les
injonctions à être soi disant féminine
ou soi-disant masculin parce que les
tireurs les sérotypes on ferme tout le
monde les filles les garçons et tous les
enfants qui se reconnaissent pas dans
ces deux cases donc on a vraiment un
pouvoir de déconstruction de ces
stéréotypes pour ouvrir les horizons et
surtout pour faire en sorte justement
que la possibilité d'être soi-même
puisse exister
donc par rapport aux stéréotypes cette
possibilité de déconstruire est vitale
et sur la question des violences
quand on va nous dire oui mais quand
même elle exagère un peu ces femmes en
disant que les violences est tout bal à
l'outil très concret c'est de revenir
aux faits lfm c'est que les violences
sexistes et sexuelles traverse toutes
les sphères que ce soit le harcèlement
sexuel au travail le harcèlement de rue
ou aussi justement la violence conjugale
rappelant en parenthèse que une femme
sur cinq en suisse est la cible de
violences conjugales et en moyenne une
femme en suisse meurent par semaine sous
les coups de sang
compagnon de son ex compagnon on quitte
la question du genre pour rentrer dans
la question des sexualités sur la
question des sexualités
premier exemple où on voit qu'il ya de
nouveaux l'épée de damoclès qui peut
tomber
par exemple un homme qui a x relation on
va l'appeler d'une certaine manière est
une femme qui a x nombre de relations
mais exactement le même nombre que
l'homme on va l'appeler d'une autre
manière et je vais non plus pas cité
comme on l'appelle mais c'est juste une
manière de dire pour que la même chose
on voit qu'on a un double standard
une fois c'est valoriser une fois cette
dévaloriser sur les sexualités il ya
aussi bien sûr l'épée de damoclès qui
peut tomber sur l'orientation affective
et sexuelle
c'est à dire par qui vous et moi on est
attirés ou attirés sexuellement et où
sentimentalement et donc par rapport à
cette question quel que soit votre
propre orientation affective et sexuelle
que je ne veux absolument pas savoir
on est bien d'accord mais que dans la
salle vous définissiez comme homos bi
hétéro ou autre une autre orientation à
quel âge précisément vous l'avez choisi
alors je sais que vous ne pas me
répondre mais je juge que vous posiez
cette question à quel âge vous l'avez
choisi parce que comme je la pose
souvent plein de fois les personnes ne
répondent surtout justement les ados h
france était à 3 mois et demi dans le
foetus de ma maman ça c'est extrêmement
intéressant et précoce d'autres
personnes vont dire c'est à la crèche
d'autres personnes pendant l'adolescence
et là on voit qu'il faut pas confondre
par qui on est attiré du moment où on
prend conscience ou du fait qu'on
n'oserait le vivre
mais la réponse est que vous et moi on
se réveille pas un beau matin en disant
un super g tombée amoureuse ou amoureux
de cette personne ou d'une autre ce qui
signifie que l'orientation c'est pas un
choix
et combien même pourquoi ce serait un
problème parce que ce qui pose problème
au contraire c'est cette phrase que
j'entends encore de manière récurrente
beaucoup de jeunes qui me dit je me sens
en sécurité nulle part
pourquoi parce que les violences tue les
jeunes homos et buisson beaucoup plus la
cible de violences et discriminations
de plus un tiers des élèves qui se
définissent hétéro sur la cible de moby
et les taux de suicide des jeunes homos
et buisson deux à cinq fois plus élevé
pas seulement parce que les violences tu
et parce que le silence tue quand je
demande aux jeunes à qui tu parles quand
tu as un problème
les jeunes très souvent me disent ah je
parle soit à mes potes à l'école ou à ma
famille les jeunes qui se pose juste des
questions sur leur orientation affective
et sexuelle me disent je cite je crève
de trouille de parler à mes potes à ma
famille à mes amis
donc là on a un vecteur extrêmement
puissant et facile à mettre en oeuvre
si une personne nous parle de son
orientation en dix ans n'est peut-être
que je suis au bout plutôt que de lui
dire ah mais c'est trop super tu es homo
et on leur mère où on la remet dans une
catégorie ou de lui dire 'ne t'inquiète
pas ça va passer on peut simplement lui
dire merci de me parler
comment tu te sens et de quoi tu as
besoin autre point sur la question des
sexualités ne l'oublions pas que les
discriminations sont extrêmement vives y
compris en suisse la suisse sur les
droits des personnes lesbiennes gays bi
trans et intersexe est à 31 %
c'est à dire que ces personnes là on 31%
droit et les terrans dans 100% c'est à
dire que le levier sociétal c'est
vraiment de se dire l'idée c'est d'avoir
les mêmes droits pas plus de droits mais
les mêmes droits on clôt maintenant cet
aspect justement lié aux sexualités on
voit que les épées de damoclès sont
aussi très fréquentes
pour remonter en généralité et mettre en
évidence que le plus important c'est
vraiment de se dire qu'on a un pouvoir
d'action parce que quand on agit on
protège les cibles on dit je te protège
toi mais on a aussi un pouvoir d'action
parce qu'on est en train de parler aux
auteurs et aux autres y sont dit c'est
inadmissible et finalement on a un
pouvoir d'action parce qu'aux témoins on
est en train de leur dire si l'épée
tombe je te protège et pour terminer en
termes de conclusion on voit que dans
ces situations là le soutien de
l'entourage reste le facteur le plus
précieux d'ailleurs je tiens à remercier
au passage ma famille de coeur ma mère
mon frère qui sont dans la salle pour
leur présence parce que finalement la
vraie question c'est qu'est ce qui pose
problème et ce qui pose problème ce ne
sont pas la diversité des devenir ce qui
pose problème c'est les violences qui
les aurait donc dernière question avant
de vous quitter
quand les épées tombe qui dans la salle
intervient déjà ou a envie
d'intervenir je vous remercie pour vos
mains qui se lèvent parce que on a un
pouvoir d'action individuellement et
collectivement
refusant les violences brisant le
silence
ouvrant les horizons il ne tient qu'à
nous de faire en sorte que chaque
devenir puisse advenir
[Applaudissements]